[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: So good
afternoon, everybody.
Welcome to the session today.
I'm really glad that
everyone is here.
Hopefully everyone has
been enjoying Google Next.
Can I get a pulse?
Is everyone enjoying
Google Next?
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome, great.
So my name's Amruta.
I'm a Product Manager on
the Google Compute Engine.
I'm joined here
today with Simon.
And together, we're going to
go through all the content
and demos that we
have planned today.
So let's get started.
So before we go
in, let's kind of
see where we're going to talk
about for the next 15 minutes
or so.
The first is I'm going to
talk a little bit about why
you should bring
your Windows server
workloads to Google Cloud.
We're going to talk about some
of the features on the platform
that customers really love
and choose Google GCP for.
Then we're going to go
through to customer journeys
that we see most commonly.
We have customers faced
with a problem of,
hey, I have all these
legacy applications
and I really need to move
off my private data center
into a cloud with
minimal refactoring
in a very time bound fashion.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about all the support
that we have on the
platform for that.
And then there's a
second customer journey
that is very common,
which is around, hey,
I want to move to the cloud,
but I want to actually make sure
that legacy applications or the
applications I have actually
use Cloud Services, kind of
have auto scaling, reliability
without me having
to write any code.
And we're going to go and
take a look at what support
we have for that journey.
And Simon is then
going to help actually
put all those tools that I
talk about to use and demo
how we can take an application
and move it in these two
different fashions.
In the end, we're going
to have Q&A. And Simon
and I will also stay back.
So if there is content
that you did not
see or have a lot of questions,
feel free to reach out to us.
So let's get started.
Why bring your workloads to GCP?
Specifically for
Windows Server, we've
been investing a lot in Windows
Server all the way since 2015.
That's when we launched our
very first Windows Server image.
Since then, there have
been a lot of improvements,
specifically for
Windows and SQL Server.
We have a wide variety
of images to choose
from, both for Windows and
SQL, different versions,
different editions.
We've also built a lot of
features that are required
for enterprise ready workloads.
So enterprises want
support for clustering.
They want support for
high availability.
They want the methods that
work on premise to also work
on Cloud and we now
have support for that.
From the developer side, if you
are a .NET developer on Google
Cloud, we've also built in a
bunch of tooling for Visual
Studios, PowerShell, and
Stackdriver for ESP .NET
logging and monitoring.
In the last nine months, based
on the customer feedback,
we've been focusing on two major
areas, migration and security.
For migration, I'll go
into a little bit of detail
as to what support we have.
And in terms of security, two
things that we've worked on
is private IP support.
We heard loud and clear
that you want make sure
that there is only private
IPs on your Windows
VMs and your SQL DMs, and
that's in preview now,
going public very soon.
So we're also going to be
very excited to announce
some features around
secure boot, which
apply to both Windows
and SQL Server VMs.
Now, that session on shielded
VMs is the product is tomorrow.
So please stay tuned
for announcements
around that in the keynote
as well as a deep dive
session at 11 o'clock.
So I'm going to go
to three reasons
as to why customers,
specifically if you're Windows,
love bringing their
workloads to GCB.
The first one is performance.
When you bring
your applications,
whether its windows,
SQL Server, or .NET,
you're actually running on the
same infrastructure that Google
runs on.
Your traffic never leaves the
Google Fiber, even when you're
going across data centers.
But what does that mean for you?
That basically means that
you get super fast latencies,
consistent throughput.
You get all the improvements
that we put into performance
to make sure that
VMs boot up fast.
You can have a large
number of VMs boot up,
so customers don't need to keep
these pools of warm VMs ready.
And you actually get the best
of our Google network for you.
So things like we've had
a lot of tests around how
our network compares
to the others,
how some of our
products like GCS, which
is Google Cloud Storage and
Google Compute Engine compare.
So there is a site
called cloudbenchmark.com
where we've published some
of these test results,
and I highly encourage
you to kind of go and take
a look at that.
The second is price.
Our philosophy has
always been to keep
pricing simple,
flexible, and try
to offer you the best price.
We have products like
sustained use discount,
where we monitor your workload.
If you're running
it steady state,
we automatically
give you a discount.
We have things like
rightsizing recommendations
that are constantly
monitoring your workload
and making sure we give
you recommendations
that will save you and recommend
the right configuration.
We have features like
per second billing,
if that is something
that you can
use to kind of get
the maximum out
of making sure that
you pay for the VMs
only up till that they are used.
One feature I'd really like
to talk about, especially
with Windows and SQL
Server, when you're
running license software
on VMs, these licenses
charge on a per vCPU.
So when you have features like
custom VMs and extended memory,
you can actually get
a lot of cost savings.
So a lot of customers,
especially when
they're running SQL Server,
they want to go for the N116.
And the first bar
over there shows you
what the estimated
cost of running
Windows with the licenses
is for a month for N116.
But let's say
you're running that
not because you need 16
vCPUs, but you really
need that 104 gigabytes of
memory because your workload
is memory intensive.
You can actually get
that using custom VMs
and extended VMs on a VM
which has lower vCPUs.
So if you want to work with the
eight core, 10 core, 12 core
VM and not a 16 core VM,
you can actually size that.
And that makes a huge
difference in the price
that you pay for licensing
as well as the base VM.
The next reason that a lot
of customers really like
is security.
So at Google, we have this
policy is we trust nothing.
We build a lot of
purpose built hardware
to make sure that we have
the full history of the stack
that we run on.
Titan is an example.
It is a custom security chip
that provides route of trust
on every GCP device.
Our investments in making sure
that we detect vulnerabilities
early and make sure
that we patch our host
systems without any performance
or downtime for our customers.
And project 0, which is
the Spectre or Meltdown
vulnerabilities is a
great example of that.
Specifically for
Windows, I'd like
to repeat that we've heard
that customers really
want private IP support
for Windows VMs,
and that's available today.
If you click on that
link or come to me later,
you can sign up and
you'll have that available
for your projects.
We also have some really
fun announcements, which
unfortunately I can't disclose.
But do attend the
session tomorrow at 11:40
to learn about secure boot
and a bunch of other features
for Windows VMs.
Lastly, reliability.
And I mentioned reliability
because as we're patching hosts
or as we are doing
our maintenance
to make sure you have
the most secure platform,
we can do that without having
to reboot your machines
or give you any
application downtime.
And this is possible
because we have technologies
like live migration.
So these are some
of the reasons where
customers like to come to
the Google Cloud Platform.
They get the best performance
for the best price,
they're guaranteed
that the systems are
secure and reliable,
and overall, you
have a great experience running
your workloads on our platform.
So now let's take
our second part.
Let's talk about our
customer journey.
So a lot of our customers have
been running their data centers
for many years.
They have a lot of
legacy applications.
And they now want to
move to the cloud, right?
They don't want to
refactor, because they
have thousands of
thousands of applications,
so they want to move as is with
minimal refactoring in a very
short time period.
So the question is, for
customers with such Windows
and SQL Server workloads,
what support do we
have in the platform for them?
So let's look at a
little bit of that.
One question I get asked
a lot, and therefore I
like to address this up front,
is what flavors of Windows
do you support?
Do you support the
latest flavors?
But we do understand
that some customers
need to have their own time
frame to how they upgrade.
So we also have
support for legacy OSs.
So with the latest and
the greatest, which
is 1709 and 1803
images, we also have
via a migration tooling
support for legacy
OSs like 2003 and 2008R1.
When customers want to migrate,
they like to know, OK, great,
the platform supports
this version.
How do I actually migrate?
And over the last
few months, we've
been working a lot on
our migration story,
giving you different options
based on your scenarios.
There are three options that I
would like to go through today.
One is the Virtual Disk Import.
The second one is our VM
migration capabilities
through Velostrata.
And the third one
is CloudEndure.
The first one is really good
if you have a few golden images
that are [INAUDIBLE]
golden disks
and that's the way you want
to spin up your infrastructure
on premise and use the
same image to spin up
your infrastructure
on the Cloud.
We recently announced our
acquisition of Velostrata,
and that adds a really
rich set of capabilities
to orchestrate mass migrations.
Last but not the least, we
have a great partnership
with CloudEndure and have
helped move many customers
over using their SaaS
based VM migration tooling.
So let's dig into this
a little bit more.
So what is the
Virtual Disk Import?
A lot of customers have
what you call golden images
or golden disks.
Now, this is your
software, your scripts
and everything pulled
into one that is certified
by your IT or security admins.
And this is what is your
[INAUDIBLE] for spinning up
infrastructure on premise.
And you probably want to
use that same on Cloud
when you spin up
infrastructure there.
So we have a really
simple command line tool
which you can download, and
with a few simple commands
you can actually
convert that disk
into an image in Google Cloud.
And just like you
spin up infrastructure
using our images, you
can use this custom image
to spin up infrastructure.
The same way as
you can import, you
can also export from GCE using
the same command line tool.
Next I'd like to talk a
little bit about Velostrata.
As I mentioned, Velostrata has
an enterprise grade migration
tooling, and we're
very, very happy
that they are now part of Google
and all these capabilities are
now available to our
customers within the platform.
What is unique about
the Velostrata offering
is they have a unique
streaming technology.
Now, what this
does is it streams
the virtual machine on demand.
And you can actually have
that VM booted in Google Cloud
without having all
the disks moved over.
In most migration
technologies, you actually
have a full copy
of the entire VM
state, all the disks
attached to it,
and then you're able to boot it.
What this really gives you
is the flexibility of having
that VM boot up
in minutes, verify
that your applications look
good, and then give a thumbs up
and continue that migration
story, or thumbs down,
reboot, start again.
You can also do things
like rightsize your VMs,
add different policies and
checks, and then kind of
continue your migration journey.
So it gives you a
lot of flexibility.
The second thing to
note about Velostrata
is it integrates really
well with VMware.
So vSphere and vCenter APIs.
They've done a great
job in making sure
that that works really well.
So if you have Windows Server
workloads or SQL Server
workloads running
on VMware, this
provides you a seamless
way to kind of move
your workloads from your VMware
workloads on premise to GCP.
We've had a lot of sessions
that probably talk about this,
and I'm happy to go
into more details.
Let's talk about
our third solution.
So we've been working with
CloudEndure for over 18 months.
They're a great partner and
have helped multiple enterprise
customers move.
This is a great solution
if you're working
in a multi-cloud environment.
So CloudEndure
solution is really
good at moving from
any source to GCP.
The way they migrate is through
block level replication.
And they have support
for all flavors
of Windows as well as Linux.
So you have three
different options
based on your requirements,
based on your workloads,
based on your timeline.
You can move and pick and choose
and move your workloads to GCP.
We also understand that in
migrations, you probably
need more support than just
information about tooling.
So we have an
organization, which
is a professional
services organization,
and this organization has worked
with many of our enterprise
customers to assess their
enterprise environment,
understand the needs
of it, do a POC,
and then figure out what is
the best strategy to migrate
to Google Cloud.
So if you go to cloud.google.com
/solutions/migrationcenter,
you'll have a lot more
information about the different
plans available.
Great, so we talked a little
bit about Windows Servers,
we talked about the
migration tooling.
Now let's talk
about your back end.
So a lot of the Windows .NET
applications that we have have
SQL Server as the back end.
So customers ask me, what
are the images you support?
Just like Windows, we try
to support all flavors
and versions of SQL Server.
And you also have to support
for two ways to license it.
You can use our
images and you can
pay as you use or you could
actually have your SQL Server
licenses brought in if you
have software assurance,
and that gives you an ability
to bring over your licenses
through license mobility.
When we think about
SQL server migrations,
customers have
different thoughts.
Some of our customers
use the migration tooling
that we just spoke about,
and some of our customers
have different
approaches to do that.
So I'd like to talk
about three approaches.
So the first one is a lot
of customers just spin up
SQL Server VMs on
GCE and then they
do a restore and backup of
their data from on premise
onto Google Cloud.
The second option is
we went through a bunch
of our migration tooling.
And if you have--
specifically, if you are trying
to bring your own copy of SQL
Server with the
license included,
a lot of our customers use
some of the migration tooling
that we just showcased.
And the last one
is log shipping.
So a lot of customers try
to do an availability group.
They have a DR SQL
Server on Google Cloud.
And they try to use
replication or log
shipping, natively supported
technologies in SQL Server
to cut over.
So now that you've
actually cut over
and landed your SQL
Server VM on GCE,
you have your
application stack, how
do you ensure that you get
some of the enterprise gate
features?
So we have support for the
two major recommendations
from Microsoft for having
highly available SQL
Servers on premise.
So the first one is
availability groups.
So you're probably familiar with
always on availability groups.
And we have support for that.
It gives you a regionally
highly available configuration.
You can keep your SQL nodes
in two different zones
in the same region or you
can have them cross region.
The good thing
about this is it's
a multi-site failable
cluster solution,
and you really don't need
a load balancer for it.
So if you look at
the documentation
that we have with just
some simple networking
rules and routing,
you can actually
have the set up really quickly.
We have a simple click
to deploy template.
So if you go to our Cloud
Marketplace and search
for SQL Server always
on availability groups,
you will see a template.
And with one click,
you can actually
deploy this and test it out.
The second option we see,
and this is typically
for SQL Server VMs that
are running before 2012.
So a lot of customers
have physical SANs.
They have their databases
connected to that.
A lot of customers
who have queries
which are across
databases still want
to have this configuration
for SQL Server HA.
And the way to kind
of support that
is we are now
figuring out how we
can build a virtual
SAN on Google Cloud
and then have both your
primary and secondary nodes
connect to it.
So the way we have
enabled this technology
is by using Storage
Space Direct, which
is a features supported
in Windows Server 2016.
What this feature
allows you to do
is it allows you to cluster
all the disks attached
to the various nodes that you
have provisioned in a Windows
cluster and present
that as a single volume
to both the nodes on the system.
So this is really cool.
It actually gives you a
virtual SAN at a very low cost.
It replicates your data
across these disks,
giving you a pretty
highly reliable solution.
So we have support for that.
We have detailed documentations.
And just like the
first use case,
we have a one click deployment
template for that too.
The third option is we've worked
with SIOS, who's a partner,
and they have a solution
called Datakeeper.
And this is very similar to
the SQL Server FCI solution
where you can actually
have SQL Server clustering
without the need for a SAN.
So they also have a
virtual SAN technology.
The difference
between SQL Server FCI
that I showed a slide
before and this is you
can actually use this
for versions of Windows
before 2016.
So if you have some
compatibility reasons where
you want to have
Windows Server 2012
and still want this
feature, this is an option.
It's also a really
cost effective option
because it works with
SQL Server Standard.
So if you have SQL
Server Standard
and you still want
to have HA, this
is one way in which
you can support it.
Cool.
So just to recap, we talked
about how you can migrate stuff
to Google Cloud.
We talked a little bit about
SQL Server and the different HA
technologies that
are supported on GCE.
Last but not the least, people
want to know about identity.
And there are three ways
in which we actually
support different Active
Directory use cases.
The first one is customers have
their users and groups defined
on their on premise Active
Directory domain controller.
And they just want to
sync this to Google Cloud
so that they can assign
the right IAM permissions
and give those users and groups
the right level of access
on Google Cloud.
And that is a
supported scenario.
We have a sync tool that
actually syncs users and groups
to a domain controller
on Google Cloud
and allows you to
assign IAM permissions.
This is great because you
actually don't have anything
from Google Cloud reaching back
into your domain controller
on premise.
So it's a nice isolated feature.
The two other ways to
move Active Directory
is a hybrid approach or an
all in approach, as I call it.
You can actually have a
full trust relationship
between a domain
controller on premise
and a domain controller
in Google Cloud.
And you can achieve this
via a VPN or interconnect.
The second option
is you actually
move your domain controllers
to the different zones
in a region.
And this option
is actually better
if you want a much higher
resilience and lower latencies,
because the traffic is
all on Google's network
and doesn't really
have to kind of go
over VPN to your on premise.
So different options
and different choices
based on your needs
and scenarios.
We cannot do justice to the
full thing of Active Directory,
but there was a session at 3:15
and I hope most folks over here
attended it.
We had a customer Capital One.
I see a few folks
who are nodding.
So we had a deep dive in
each one of these methods.
And we also had a
customer, Capital One,
come and showcase how they
actually moved their Active
Directory over.
So if you missed that
session, please look up IO
274 or come and
talk to us and we'll
help you get more
information there.
Cool.
So last but not the least,
if you're a .NET developer
on a platform, you
have a lot of support.
So you have Cloud Tools
for Visual Studio.
You also have support for
.NET Core, both on GKE,
which is our Google Kubernetes
Engine, as well as GAE,
which is Google App Engine.
We've also added some really
cool features in Stackdriver,
which allow you to
debug your .NET code,
your .NET production code live.
And Simon is going
to talk a little bit
and show a little bit about
that in the next demo.
So I'm going to hand
it over to Simon
to demo how we use
some of these tools.
So we're going to take a
really legacy application
and just lift and
shift it to the Cloud.
SIMON ZELTSER: All right.
Thanks, Amruta.
So let's talk about
this demo a little bit.
So we are going to
talk about application,
which is really old legacy
application from 2006,
.NET Framework 2.0.
There is a monolithic
web front end
talking to multiple databases.
And we are going to just lift
and shift this application
as it is into Google Cloud.
So let's go into the demo.
OK.
So let's first see what
our application does.
So this is a really old
sample of e-commerce shop.
With the old stack, you
can explore categories,
you can buy stuff,
you can log in.
So basically yet another
e-shop application.
So let's go into
the Google Console
and see that essentially
what we need to do
is deploy it under
Compute Engine.
So we will have two instances.
One of them will run
IIS with the front end
and another one
will run SQL Server
with all those databases.
Now, Amruta spoke about the
database piece quite a bit,
so I'll focus on the IIS piece.
So let's go into Visual
Studio for a minute.
And this is the
code of our demo.
Everything is available
and you can later on
refer to the full example
that we are demoing here
in the reference slides.
So I downloaded Cloud
Tools for Visual Studio.
And then if I go into the Tools
and then Google Cloud Tools
and Show Cloud
Explorer, you can see
different artifacts
of our Cloud,
including Google Compute Engine.
So if we want to deploy a new
instance of IIS up and running,
I just do right click
and New ASP.NET instance.
And that will open a
screen where I just
need to hit on this button
and that will make it work.
Basically, it will
one click deploy
the VM, configure
Windows and IIS for me,
as well as all the
networking settings
that we need to set up.
I can use this Cloud Tools
for some other stuff as well.
It will make me a
lot more productive.
For example, I can go
into Firewall Options
and then decide to open
up some more ports.
For example, if I want
Visual Studio Remote
Debugger or some other things,
I can just tweak it here.
Everything can be also done
through the command line
or through the UI, but this
is really very convenient way
to do things from within
your integrated development
environment.
So that's our first
demo, and over to Amruta.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR: Great.
So this was a really,
really simple application.
And in a matter
of a few minutes,
you could actually spin up both
the VM as well as the back end
and have your application up
and running on Google Cloud.
So let's kind of talk a little
bit more about this journey
and how you can
modernize it more.
So before we go into some
of the options available,
the question is, why modernize?
And talking to
customers, they come up
with generally three
pieces of feedback.
Folks want to modernize
because they want
to reduce cost and complexity.
If you just lift
and shift VMs as is,
you're going to save
on hardware cost.
You're going to run on
Google great infrastructure.
But you still have a monolithic
application and you cannot size
it or change it up easily.
The second one is
speed and agility.
So as you kind of saw,
the pet shop application,
you kind of noticed
that there were
a few different pieces to it.
There was an ordering, there was
a catalog, there was a product,
and there was a web front end.
Now, let's say your site
becomes really, really popular
and the load suddenly spikes.
Let's say Black
Friday and people just
want to buy a lot of goldfish.
You don't have the ability to
very quickly scale up or scale
down your ordering part
of that application.
So people want to break
this up into micro services
so they have the ability
to turn up and turn down
things as the load changes.
Third is cross-platform support.
As we go into the
world of Cloud,
customers want to
make sure that they
have the flexibility of
running on multiple clouds
and in multiple environments.
Customers want to be able to run
their workloads on their choice
of operating system.
So these are some
of the main concerns
as to customers have and
some of the motivation
they have to actually reconsider
how these applications are
architected.
There are many ways to
modernize your applications.
You could completely refactor.
You could use more
managed services.
Today we want to talk
about modernizing
by moving to
containers, because this
is one of the most
popular areas,
and we've got a lot
of feedback over here
that this is a really
great way that customers
want to move their workloads
and modernize them.
So let's see what
support we have for them.
So today you can actually--
Windows Server 2016 was the
first version of Windows that
had support for containers.
So it had support for
the Docker engine.
We have support for container
optimized Windows Server
images.
So just like you have that
whole list of Windows images,
you can actually take an
image, take a Windows container
optimized image.
It has your Docker images
already pulled for you
with the right
networking settings
and you can just deploy a
Windows container on it.
If you want to go
more cross-platform,
Microsoft introduced ASP.NET
Core or .NET Core technologies,
and they've been constantly
investing in moving a lot
of the libraries from
.NET to .NET Core.
And this actually gives
you the flexibility
of running it either
on a Windows container
or on a Linux container.
So if you were to kind of double
up on .NET Core and run it
on a Linux container, you can
actually now move that entire
workload running
on GC, GKE, or GAE.
So GKE is Kubernetes,
managed Kubernetes service,
and Google App Engine.
So if you absolutely don't
want to do any management,
GAE is your better bet.
So a little bit about why you
should bring these containers
to Google Cloud.
Everything at Google
runs in a container.
All the demos you see, all
the different services that we
have, they all are
container based.
We launch an average of about
four billion new containers
per week.
And this has really
allowed us to improve
the tooling and our
systems for managing
these containers at scale.
We've also been contributing to
a pretty successful open source
project, which I
think a lot of you
will be familiar
with, Kubernetes.
And we're constantly adding more
and more improvements to that
as well as it's great to see
all the work that the developer
community has done to make
this project successful.
Just like we have support
for Linux containers
and Kubernetes, there's
also an open source project
and a working group that's
looking at Windows container
support, and we are actively
involved in that group.
So now let's kind of look at how
we can take our really, really
old PetShop application
and modernize
that using some of the
tools we just spoke about.
So I'm handing it
over back to Simon.
SIMON ZELTSER: Thanks, Amruta.
So this is just a reminder
of the simple architecture
of our PetShop application.
And now what we want to do
is slightly modernize it.
So in this case,
you can see that we
will try to expose some
of that functionality
as micro services.
So we'll still have a front
end, which is Windows and IIS,
and that will work against
three micro services, orders,
product, and profile.
Those in turn will work
against managed databases.
So why doing that?
So you get a lot of
architectural benefits
from doing that such as
auto scaling or basically
a lot of good
scenarios for doing
scaling with Google
infrastructure
as well as very good and easy
integration with Visual Studio
and Stackdriver debugger, which
I'll show you in a few moments.
So let's delve into the demo.
So it's the same
PetShop application,
but this time it will work using
a bit different architecture.
So I already did some pre work
by exposing the functionality
as micro services.
If you have ASP.NET
MVC services and you
want to move them
to ASP.NET Core,
there is a relatively
easy path to do that.
If not, you will have to
create your ASP.NET Core
services from
scratch and gradually
move your functionality over.
So I already did that.
And in this case, we'll talk
about taking that and basically
doing containerization.
So I added a Docker file.
I'll demo that on one
of the micro services,
but we need to do it
for the three of them.
So this is the Docker file.
You define the image, that base
image that you want to use,
and in Google, we support
multiple ASP.NET Core images
for different purposes.
So you can base off of one of
the images that we support.
You define how to run your
application, which parts
to expose, and some of
the environment variables
that may be useful for
running this properly
on the Google Cloud.
And then, essentially,
once we do that,
we need to build
the container image
and push it into a
container registry.
So let's take a look at some
existing container registry
images that are
already pre-created.
So let's go into
Orders, for example.
And you can see here that
these are different images
that they pushed.
I can tag them.
And then essentially,
the whole point
is that we can create
Kubernetes cluster, which
will run our micro
services in containers
using one of the images that we
pushed into container registry.
And then we can get a lot
of benefits of Kubernetes.
So let's take a look
at some of that.
So what I can do is run
a command line cloud
as the case shell.
So I'll run a command which
will show that we already
have a cluster, Kubernetes
cluster, that I pre-created.
I'll show you in a
moment how to do that.
So this command can
show you that we
run the micro services in pods.
And pod is the minimal
deployment unit for Kubernetes.
So you scale your
micro services in pods.
You deploy them into pods.
And you can see that
for every micro service,
we have one pod up and running.
In order to create
Kubernetes cluster,
you can just go
into this web UI.
Under Kubernetes Engine,
there is an option
to do that by clicking
on Create Cluster.
There are also other options
available, such as command line
tools that you can use.
So essentially, to
create the cluster,
you just need to
fill up the name
of the cluster, the location,
the version of Kubernetes
that you want to
deploy, and then there
are certain features that
you can make available,
such as Stackdriver
logging and monitoring.
And if you open this
More thing and then
scroll all the way
down, you can see
that we are pretty
secure offering in here,
because we can
basically define what
Google services will be
available from that Kubernetes
cluster.
I can do that for all the API.
I can do that with
full granularity.
So in our later
sample, we're going
to show how we can
use Cloud Debugger.
So for that, we need to go all
the way down and then enable
Cloud Debugging feature
and then, essentially, we
can click on Create and that
will create our Kubernetes
cluster.
So let's say that we have
Kubernetes cluster up
and running already.
Let's see what we
can do with this.
So one thing I can do is just
run kubectl get deployments.
Now, kubectl is the
command line tool
to manage your
Kubernetes clusters.
For those who are
not familiar, we
are going to use this to
talk to our PetShop cluster
that I already pre-created.
You can see that we have
three deployments here.
One and one meaning that
we wanted one copy of each
and we actually get
one copy of each.
But the whole power is what
happens when we want to scale.
So with Kubernetes, you get
this scaling capabilities
basically for free,
and it makes it
very efficient by
taking care of all
the scalability work for you.
So you can do kubectl
scale deployment.
And let's say we want
to scale order service.
And I want to have
three replicas.
So what this command does,
it basically tells Kubernetes
that we want to spin up two more
instances of our deployment,
and Kubernetes will do all
the heavy lifting for us.
And to kind of check on
that, we can just run,
again, the kubectl
get deployments.
And you can see here that now
the desired and the current
changed to the three,
just like we asked.
We can also run kubectl get
pods and see these are the three
instances that were created.
So we basically just
run one single command
and Kubernetes was able
to scale our ASP.NET Core
application really easy.
Now let's scale back.
So in this case, I'll just
go back to one replica.
And we can run get pods again.
And in this case, you can
see that the two replicas
that we want to kill there are
in the process of being killed.
And essentially, we'll have one
instance of every micro service
up and running.
OK, so that's all good.
We can scale with Kubernetes
and Kubernetes will take care
of the scaling capabilities.
But there is more to that.
So what if we want to handle
resiliency for our services?
So let's try to kill one of the
pods, which will essentially
kill our micro service,
and see what happens.
So first of all, I'll run
kubectl get pods again
to just kind of confirm
the starting state.
And now we basically want to
kill one of the micro services
and see what happens once it
runs under Kubernetes cluster.
So kubectl delete pod.
And I'll just copy
the name of that pod.
And you can see
that it was deleted.
Now if I run kubectl
get pods, you
can see two copies
of that profile.
Sorry, so one is
terminating, and another
is running, which is
actually very interesting.
Because what happens
here is that the one
that is terminating is that
copy that we tried to kill.
So it takes time until
it actually gets killed.
But then Kubernetes
was smart enough
to recognize that we desire to
run one instance of a profile
service.
So if your service was affected
and essentially failed,
Kubernetes will bring
another copy of that service
back up automatically for you.
If you have multiple
copies, it will do that
with multiple copies as well.
So by just moving to Kubernetes
with your ASP.NET Core
workload, what
you're able to get
is full handling of
resiliency as well as scaling
capabilities, which is
really, really cool.
Now, another thing that
we might want to consider
is the feature called
Stackdriver Debugger.
Now, this feature
currently is in preview.
But the fact that we are
running in Google Cloud
Platform with ASP.NET Core
allows us to do the following.
So I'll open my debug screen
on the Google Cloud Console.
And you will see here
that this is basically
the screen where
we can production
debug our application.
Now, it sounds like
a bold statement.
But this is actually what it is.
What this application
allows us to do
is opening the source
code of our application,
attaching the break point to
existing running application
in production, and then
inspecting the snapshot
that Stackdriver will
take from our application
if we hit that particular
code pass, which
leads to the break point.
So let's try and see
how we can do that.
So in this case, I can
bring my source code
from multiple locations.
We have integration with GitHub,
GitLab, Bitbucket, Cloud Source
Repositories of Google Cloud,
as well as you can also
bring your own sources.
So this is what I will do.
I'll take my local sources
and I'll hit Upload.
Now, this is not really
uploading into Cloud.
This is just opening that
locally on my browser.
And you can see this is the
code of the application.
We'll try to debug
service code products.
And if we explore
some of its code,
there is this
category controller.
And we can just go and
explore what it does.
But one of the actions
here called category.
And we can see that it
tries to use caching.
So if caching is
enabled, we might use it.
Otherwise we will not use it.
So let's inspect whether
caching is actually enabled.
So that this kind of modeling
the real world scenario
where you have something
running in production.
Something happens.
You want to understand what is
the state of your application
without re-deploying with
additional instrumentation
that you might want to add.
So you can just add your
break point at the place
where you want to stop.
And now it's waiting
to hit that code pass.
Now, how do we know how
to get into this method?
So in Kubernetes,
I did some pre-work
which was exposing all my micro
services with external IP.
So I created load balancer
object and I exposed
my micro services externally.
So I'll run kubectl
get services.
And this will return all
of my services running
under Kubernetes with
their external IP.
We are talking about
the product service.
So I'll just copy this
external IP from here.
And if we look at
the source code,
there is this route
called category.
So in order to reach this
code pass, what we need to do
is go into this IP and
then slash category.
So let's do that.
So this opens some
information, which
is categories of our PetShop.
And let's go back into debugger.
So you can see here that
suddenly it shows all the call
stack of that code pass.
So basically, we
hit the break point.
There is the call stack
of what really happens up
until that point.
This is the real application.
And also we are able to
see here all the variables
and their state at that moment
when this snapshot was taken.
So I can open up this
state and then take
a look at this caching
enabled variable.
You can see it's 0,
which means false.
This kind of gives
me the idea of what's
going on with my application.
Now, all those snapshots are
really a powerful feature.
And there is almost no
overhead to run that.
So you can run that
in production safely.
You can be sure
that it will not run
on all of your CPU or memory.
The overhead is almost
next to nothing.
And it gives you this
powerful capability
of exploring your application
state if you really need that.
And then there is also
this snapshot history.
So you can share this
state with other developers
by just sending them link
into the relevant snapshot
and essentially
get to know what's
going on with your application.
All right, so let's switch back.
AMRUTA GULANIKAR:
Cool, so hopefully we
demonstrated to you how easy
it was to just lift and shift.
And Simon just
demonstrated to you
some of the amazing
capabilities that just light up
if you were to re-factor and
move this to Microsoft Services
on GKE.
A lot of the work was
sort of done and sort of
explained quickly because
we have a short time,
but we have a detailed
set of White Papers
that we wrote with one of our
Windows partners, Magenic,
and they go into an extremely
detailed explanation
for the same application
of how you could move
and the different
pieces and the tools.
And all the work done
is actually available.
The code's available, so
you're free to kind of look
at some of the examples
and see how we did
some of the migration there.
In addition to that, we'd
like to also leave you
with some of the links.
So if you go to
cloud.google.com/windows or SQL
Server, we have a lot more
information and White Papers
and best practices.
And we also have, similarly,
information about our developer
tools.
So we will probably be
sharing these slides
after the sessions.
So these are really good
links to kind of go and get
more information.
[MUSIC PLAYING]